l'amour road sur le plateau par love
tu vois le guerre longue et je peux pas
comprendre à casablanca entre dalle un
ami travaille également à mes côtés qui
n'est pas mon bras droit mais mon
testicule gauche au crâne amis et daniel
mot ait eu un rapprochement mais hier il
ya eu un rebondissement
eh oui isabelle morini bosc est
intervenue et quand isabelle intervient
sous faites vous ce qui fait dire à me
menacer désolé à les attraper la lettre
recommandée là mais seulement
isabelle a mis son grain de sel dans
cette affaire et ce n'est plus venu à
grain de sel
mais un grain de sable regardez résumé
de l'épisode précédent et juste après
yann le bachelor fera sur ce plateau
c'est parti d'assumer
ces dames ans dans les merguez de
l'amour alors que yann le collaborateur
de cyril passé plus de temps à essayer
de refourguer sa marque guess dans un
poêle et qu'à travailler sous le harnais
des macros des macros débris et que j'ai
fait ça tous il semble qu'il n'est à ce
jour toujours pas trouvé couscous à sa
merguez la vie étant bien fait
au même moment sur la même chaîne une
certaine daniel moreau dit daniel hommes
cherchaient encore et toujours
désespérément merguez à son couscous ou
temps des toits sentiment pas loin eyes
et pas vu depuis un petit moment mais ça
va changer
heureusement elle pouvait compter sur
série son ami de longue date pour
l'aider avec bienveillance
est-ce que vous avez des vues sur
quelqu'un m'a signalé ce pays où on la
connaît pas c'est autre chose
à défaut de trouver augustine ce sera
finalement avec liane que la belle
daniel horain day
je me noie un peu dans ses yeux art l
ade magnifier suis complètement
subjuguée par daniel tout semblait donc
aller pour le mieux et ne leur restait
plus qu'à filer le parfait amour
mais c'était sans compter sur la
trahison d'isabelle morini bosc qui est
sensible elle aussi au charme de la
merguez de yade et il est splendide
c'est un des plus beaux hommes que j'ai
vu deux visages ou enore une question
subsiste alors
mais à qui il ya une remettra-t-il ça
mais rien
tu va repartir avec une bergère guest de
liane la hem d y comme on l'appelle dans
le métier je vais demander chic à yann
qui s'est mis sur son 31
il revient justement d'une bar mitzvah
sion dunkerque il ya quatre ans il a
fait les édifices le beh lourd alors ça
c'est le beh l'ouganda il a tous voila
mais c'est parce que c'est une parodie
bretagne et vous babef magnifique vous
avez vous deux prétendantes ici et dieu
sait qu'il a de la chance aux petits
veinards the sugar on va passer à la
première épreuve
d'après les preuves de la séduction
je vous demande et isabelle de bien
vouloir venir vous asseoir on va
discuter avec vous pendant 30 secondes
[Musique]
c'est dingue c'est absurde il est sympa
mais il a des problèmes oculaires
oui c'est à couper si si elle est allée
là même un peu trop grande d'ailleurs
comment allez-vous isabelle gentil donné
des piscines où vous voyez c'est plus
sain pour gagner du temps
alors c'est avec moi j'ai rien préparé
est-ce que je suis super daniel m'avoir
préparer tout retrait pour vous séduire
je vous entends tu as un truc arrive
déjà j'ai vu que je suis c'est sûr mais
daniel elle aura préparé tout un texte à
vous dire moi je suis venue spontanément
comme ça
parce que moi vous êtes mon bachelor d'
isabelle je sais que la danse voulez
qu'on vous fasse une petite dans ces
petites salles et oui
alexis est pas trop mais pas trop fait
attention attention
une largesse d'écart entre eux c'est
beau c'est beau persillade
attention la deuxième prétendante
sedania merci les gars ça ne s'est
jamais on s'est pris vraiment ri voilà
pour l'instant on sait pas si ça va se
faire donc ça tu peu prématuré à voir
avec une rue il ya deux prétendantes
rouillac de prétendre qu'un avion est
heureusement phares du président c'est
toujours les mêmes avec ma vie
enfin cette petite table que cyril nous
avait promise et alors c'est vrai qu'ils
avaient la raison suis très ému et quand
on est ému on ne sait plus trop quoi
dire je vous ai préparé un petit poème
bah oui parce que je peux pas tout miser
sur le physique j'ai un peu lucide si
alors j'attendrai par les plus humbles
après tard c'est un plat qui se mange
froid
peut-être même chose j'attends depuis
longtemps qu'un beau mec me déniaise si
tu as le courage c'est même mon sexe
enfin ravie chantera la marseillaise si
tu aimes l'ancien je te mettrai à l'aise
là est idéal suffit qu'elle se taise
elle est tellement âgée le sucre aura
les fraises je suis tellement bouillante
jeu greer est à merguez maintenant la
danse a laissé encore la reine
daniel dans ce cas là le bachelot 1 m 87
65 kg 1 une bête
une merveille le rush lourd oui je parle
de voir si je parle dans des cas m il
est magnifique et il a deux prétendants
qui ne demandent qu'une seule chose ça
m'a rien c'est qu'il pose ce merguez sur
leur beau barbecue c'est très imagé
c'est vraiment vrai une seule chose est
en plein roman c'est qu'il met sa
tartine de grippe qui le bachelor
va-t-il choisir
daniel moreau daniel moreau qui n'a pas
vu le loup depuis 20 ans à l'aï pas vu
au louvre et puis maintenant et isabelle
morini bosc
c'est un autre dédié yann oui choisissez
celle avec qui vous avez envie d'aller
signer la semaine prochaine
donnez votre merguez et attention
choisissez le bon barbeuk un choix tabou
de joigny siens ont ils été les
spectateurs ont voté également chez eux
et les téléspectateurs sont sur daniel
moreau apparemment c'est le plaisir
et oui ils ont choisi de sape leur
barbecue barbecue bon écoutez moi je
suis c'est très difficile instinct choix
très difficiles entre isabelle j'aime
énormément aidé plus longtemps et
danièle seux ce poème extrêmement c'est
sam est allé droit au coeur
j'ai obligé de choisir quel maillot
gagnent ces quelques passages que vous
avez préféré celui sur mon âge
yann je vais vous dire la touche anodine
oui car votre coeur peut aimer deux
femmes mais votre merguez doit choisir
un peu en pensant faire qu'un barbecue
j'avais une merguez ne peut pas gagner
sur de barbe quand même pas deux mois
ces deux zips d'accord il va falloir que
je me décide peut-être bête ma manière
je décroche la merguez et menez vous
[Rires]
mais je vous rappelle que vous irez
dîner la semaine prochaine dans ma loge
j'ai des bonnes nouvelles en fin de
cours et après bien sûr advienne que
pourra
vous faites les tests bien sûr de leur
copie j'ai pris ma décision
vers la personne que vous avez choisi
avec julien
isabelle je vous offre ma mère non mais
il va bien
guichard isabelle b s'est amusé à
écouter et s'ils sont comme ça avec sa
mère galles ça promet un vous merci
daniel